o pessoal bem vindos e hoje vou ensinar
como fazer uma moto ou então um triciclo
utilizando o motor do drive do
computador ok só se estiver em um
computador velho vão lá de montou drive
e vocês vão encontrar o motorzinho que
eu vou usar neste projeto e também já
usei no outro projeto que o projeto do
gerador elétrico e como vocês podem ver
um estado como o instrutor é obrigatório
vocês podem conectar diretamente na
bateria que vai continuar na mesma
então vamos lá pessoal primeiro tem que
rolar uma folha com se fosse uma hora e
foi aquela das feiras
mas se você já deve estar muito
habituados a fazer isso né quase todos
os projetos começam desta maneira e
depois vão ter que usar uma folha volta
do modo fazer um tubo
lazzarotto tem agora um pedaço grande
passado um lado ou outro vai ficar todo
time
como vocês podem ver que um cidadão de
três rãs e um tubinho e agora vou
começar a moldar aqui é parte de nossas
de carroçaria parceria dos carros
então pronto basicamente a estrutura da
mota o 3 5 2 já que inicialmente fez um
triângulo isósceles você já tem dois
lados iguais
vou dar um passo tudo mais ou menos
assim ao huoc
vejam que estou marcar um lugar no meu
punho da fita é ele ir para em que entre
as partes mercados ficam os passos que
não tem fita não cair então tem que
deixar essa parte assim para depois
encaixar um interruptor se vocês tiverem
a parte branca e por dentro de um
tubinho e vou encaixar um eixo para
movimentar pois a roda da frente e toca
para não ficar essas bordas assim por
fora para fazer o atlético estava
querendo lado ficaram cada um o outro
tem que andar com fita para não ser lá
foi a cair e fazer o volante por fazer
voando não sabe cortar dos pedacinhos
iguais
depois mudarem ela
como é algo que vocês têm um colar na
parte de cima em lados opostos dois
pronto já está mais ou menos feita a
estrutura principal só falta assinar as
rodas a parte eletrônica é eis então
vejo que eu vou usar que o bullying é
uma bolinha do sul
se vocês quiserem podem usar o youtube
em qualquer choque
tem que rolar nesta parte aqui e depois
vai para o entedia encaixar lá outro
eixo das rodas de trás eu vou usar 4 em
pinheiros mas vocês podem usar duas só
vou usar quatro porque vai ficar mais
resistente até agora vocês usarem uma
casa lá tem que acrescentar um pouco de
cola é para rodas fiquem fixa só aí vou
encaixar que bateria de 9 volts ou foram
pedindo cola que o instrutor que terei
de um brinquedo velho estava estragado
vocês não podem ficar nessa parte só deu
assim a lei foi pensado depois encaixar
lá um interruptor água é e água porque
eu vou usar aqui incluindo o ferro de
solda
agora se vocês forem crianças têm que
ajudar muito o toque não podem fazer
isso sozinhos e também nem sequer é
preciso usar em vocês ferro vocês
conseguem simplesmente conectar os cabos
usando fita para aprender lá aí uns
ambiente fita para que lhes parte do dos
cargos e ficam encostados às partes que
necessária
é e pronto
o drive do computador de montado só você
sobre o drive vão dar logo com como eu
não gravei quando eu tirei é museu fazer
o projeto e vamos dar um jeito vai falar
de montar aqui e conectar os cabos um
positivo e outro negativo do motor
vou colar a cantora numa numa tampinha
convém fique bem centralizado cae que é
um caso difícil fazer isso é e teclar no
haiti agora como é que vocês vão fazer
você expõe o cabo névoa teria pra ver
para que lado é que roda a roda em ok e
consoante se expõe onu a 21 no outro
lado do eixo rock
vocês podem ver é mandando muito bem
aqui advogar por que então tá um
capítulo gozo ok vocês fizeram uma
superfície plana vai com muita
velocidade
se vocês quiserem que vai com mais
velocidade e só foram lhe um elástico na
rotina frente e aumentar a aderência
então e só espero que tenha gostado você
quiser ajudar o canal se você é um wiki
e se inscreveu para acompanhar essas
coisas que eu faço é estomatite e amanhã